good morning from Southeastern turkey
we're in adiaman where 70 of the city
has been damaged the other 30 percent
completely wiped out rescue teams only
reached here just over a day ago the
city has been trying to cope on its own
since the earthquake struck there's no
power no heat no water no food
all running out the people left without
a home have Precious Little Shelter some
reports suggest there are no tents
available in some buildings we believe
one to two hundred people are still
trapped the building behind me thought
to have a hundred people trapped beneath
the rubble the Turkish president has
admitted shortcomings in his country's
response to the world's deadliest
earthquake in more than a decade as
anger from families grows let's give you
the key points should we more than 15
000 people are now known to have died
with that number sadly expected to rise
president erdogan has admitted there
were problems with his government's
initial response to the earthquake in
southern turkey he's also promised no
one would be left homeless turkey's
foreign minister said the country is
working on opening two more Border Gates
with Syria to allow the flow of
humanitarian Aid to its earthquake hit
neighbor but admitted that damage to the
Syrian side of the road is causing
difficulties I want to show you around
yesterday we were at an aid center those
people were the lucky ones in that
tented City they were out they may have
not had anything but at least they were
out from under the rubble have a look at
this building watch the step Nathan as
you come up
so you can see that the building has
collapsed here this was previously a
supermarket uh above that an eight-story
block of flats
just pausing for the lady behind us who
is obviously mourning the loss of some
of her loved ones
the last people to have been pulled out
of this building were a young husband
and wife and their six-month-old baby
the couple had their arms wrapped around
that little one no survivors is what
were being Charles Siobhan is with me
she has more information Siobhan
Rescuers telling us something about a
column here yeah so if you look in front
of us here you can see the whole roof of
the supermarket has collapsed and we're
being told that there was a central
column that should have been holding
that up but to make more space inside
that was removed which made all of the
supermarket very weak so that fell and
then the apartments on top fell on top
as well now we know hundreds of people
are inside I just spoke to someone who
said they still believe at least a
hundred people are under the rubble here
and we're on the third day
the temperatures are freezing many
people here are expecting now sadly to
find bodies rather than people alive
they said that when the first Quake
happened they could hear people knocking
but when the second Quake happened all
of the noise stopped and they're
expecting to find a lot of the bodies
gathered together at the exit yes
because people were Sheltering you know
they'd come out because of the first
Quake they were potentially waiting to
make their next move and then this
second massive Quake happened hours
later they thought they were probably
safe by then that they could wait for
emergency services but they just weren't
and all of this falling now on a
backdrop in Turkey of people questioning
why has AIDS taken so long to get here
so this is one of the places where they
say that for days they didn't have
anyone here so when people were knocking
there wasn't anyone here to help them
and we thought that president erdogan
was visiting some of the hardest hit
places he knows about the criticism but
he said in response this is a time for
unities and solidarity in a period like
this I cannot stomach people conducting
negative campaigns for political
interest and to that end they've
arrested people yes so there's very
strict cyber laws here and they've been
doing investigation as part of that they
said that they identified 18 people that
they said they believed had put out
provocative posts and five of those
people will go on trial oh my goodness
me now we did film some images shortly
before we came on a giving people an
idea just looking here that was
obviously somebody's you know part of
somebody's uh sofa seti previously we
saw a vacuum cleaner in the rubbish and
and you were pointing out we saw some
books earlier children's books terrible
around the corner I saw people very
carefully picking up piles of books and
piling them onto the pavement and on top
of them was a Christmas card that a
child had obviously made with the
Snowman on the front and then there were
children's story books and then someone
brought out a wedding album of a couple
on the front it's just it's terrible
showing you the people who had been in
here and we just don't know of those
people who who has survived and who
hasn't yeah I mean this is the debris
that we're talking about when you see
things like that when you see the vacuum
cleaner when you see the printer when
you see the children's books you realize
you know
these people were just going about you
know they most of them were slumbering
some of them getting up getting ready
for work and this building came down on
top of them they're saying because a
pillar had because a lot of the
buildings around you know they're
damaged they're not habitable but they
are still standing up yeah and I think
like you say you drive through the city
and you'll see a few collapsed and then
one absolutely fine and it does make you
think was that where that building was
weaker but also we've seen so much pure
grief here today women in groups huddled
round together wailing absolutely
distraught just cannot comprehend the
loss one woman here told me that there's
been an apocalypse uh we'll come back to
you for now thanks come with me if you
would please um Nathan I just want to
show our viewers those pictures that we
were just talking about a second ago all
these people are gathering around
um lighting fires for warmth it gets
bitterly cold here uh particularly at
night and there's a group of ladies that
have set up camp if you will just over
here they know that there is no hope at
all really of finding their loved ones
alive not least because they will have
been trapped under that Rubble now for
more than 72 hours the golden period
that has been described for being able
to find people alive of course there are
times when that is different but just be
careful here Nathan they're throwing the
debris down but these are the books that
we were hearing about little ones that
had been studying and learning from
these books just a couple of days ago
and the rescue workers although it looks
like organized chaos were very carefully
very gingerly bringing these down and
placing them here these will be lasting
memories for those who have lost their
loved ones including that Christmas card
on the top there that was obviously made
by a child for a family member let's
bring in yusra should she uh she's uh
should we I should say um she's in
gaziante just an hour from the Syrian
border
um hello to you yusra the latest where
you are please
okay
I mean just as you said okay people
setting up fires we've met residents
that have spent the night here unable to
go back into the building surrounding
the area but also families sleeping here
in the cold temperatures waiting to hear
news you know it's it's very different
we were at the site yesterday and we saw
the emotion we saw the atmosphere change
over time initially it was shock then it
transformed into this excruciating grief
with people screaming with Agony and as
bodies were pulled out and today there
is just a flattened sense of
disappointment and despair with people
really not having any hope that their
loved ones will come out alive and I
think that's the reality of being here
on the fourth day outside of the golden
window as you called it where really it
would take a miracle for people to come
out and be breathing but also this is a
place of Refuge for syrians that fled
the war people have come here from
Aleppo Syria and spent 10 years building
a life to now be displaced once again
yesterday we went to a playground where
syrians had set up makeshift tents with
using tarp and had said that they
remembered the days of the war being in
the cold without a home and that they
they felt a sense of solidarity once
again with their families with the
people that they left behind and in
Syria there's a the multiplied
catastrophe of not only experiencing the
conflict but also experiencing the
devastation of the very same earthquake
without Aid being able to get through
with little access being isolated by
regime forces russian-backed regime
forces the death toll is probably much
higher than we've heard but also their
protests reported protests on the border
babelowa which is not far from here
because people are so frustrated that
body bags of syrians have managed to
make it across but not much needed Aid
and support
okay uh thanks very much just to move
around to the other side of this pile of
debris that was once an eight-story
building about 100 people as we were
hearing uh from Siobhan still trapped
beneath this wreckage a lot of them
gathered at the exit of this building
they were hoping for uh help they were
hoping for helpless people shouting at
us as we as they go by wanting us to go
and film where they are and of course we
will move along later on and see other
damage in this city 70 of it has been
damaged the other 30 percent doesn't
exist anymore as I was saying a hundred
people are still trapped underneath both
of them towards the exit gathered
together hoping for Rescuers to come
they didn't come for days it's local
people who have been doing most of the
work here and this is the daily that
they have pulled away from the main side
in order to search for others well more
rescue teams are joining the search now
for some families the grief of the
weight for the news of loved ones is
followed by the grief of the answer they
didn't want to ever hear John Sparks
reports from kanamanara the epicenter of
the earthquake and a warning that his
report does show images of people who
have died
The Heart Of This Disaster lies at the
end of the road in a mountain city
called karaman marash
the fault line ruptured underneath their
feet forcing tens of thousands into
plastic tents
but they have managed to survive the
Quakes and tremors
when many of their neighbors have not
they call this area the Abra District
it's home to a series of apartment
buildings but nine blocks have been
ripped from their foundations
their occupants buried in disorderly
tombs
we saw volunteers clambering over the
concrete looking for signs of life
foreign
but the bodies of those who have lost
their lives were visible between the
cracks
when the volunteers find a mattress when
they find a bed
they know they're likely to find a body
as well because the earthquake struck at
night and most people were asleep
and I think they found another body here
[Applause]
further up we heard a tortured cry from
the man on the left
the volunteers had found the body of his
12 year old daughter wrapped in a
blanket which had laid on her bed
carried down the slope by her uncle as
he called out her name
Layla he cried Layla
have you checked to see if she's alive
or not do you know if she's alive
but the girl had passed away
we found her father called Juma actop
and he wanted to say a few words how do
you feel now I'm sure that you have been
looking for her since the earthquake
strike I'm at uh
friends and relatives gathered near the
rubble hoping for something like a
miracle but they were also angry the
first excavator had only just arrived
together
some are trying volunteers and others
who think the residents at Abra still
have a chance at life
and we were taken to see a Survivor
there's a person in this van who has
just been rescued has just been pulled
out of the rubble so we're going to try
and have a word
foreign
Mustafa spent two days in the rubble and
he thinks many residents could have been
rescued
up tomorrow
[Music]
a small group gathered in front of block
a they could see their relatives through
a slit in the concrete but they couldn't
crawl inside
this woman couldn't hide her distress
my brother was alive for 15 hours and
nobody came to help us my brother was
alive she says
[Music]
the Turkish government says it's doing
everything it can the rescue operation
is improving every day
but this city at the epicenter is
struggling to cope with grief and
devastation
John Sparks Sky News
tell um
Sue Klein ever higher we have seen Aid
coming from the UK in the by the
government but we've also seen
firefighters heading this way as well
let's bring in Matt rack should we um
he's the head of the fire brigade Union
I wonder if we could start with that
please first Matt many of your members
heading this way to do what they can
good morning okay yes so we have uh
specialists in the vine rescue service
at fire brigade junior members and they
many of them have traveled all over the
world to disasters such as earthquakes
included in this occasion and I want to
pay tribute to them obviously uh it's a
remarkable work they're doing in most
appalling circumstances
the next strike followed an increased
payoff for uh during lengthy talks with
the employers what can you tell me yeah
so we were at a meeting with the
employers late into the night last night
and we have a revised payoffer we
haven't called any strikes so we haven't
postponed anything but we simply regret
we've decided that we will not call any
strikes while we consult our members it
is an improved payoffer it's still below
inflation but it's a two-year offer of
seven percent and five percent uh that
is a change and that we have agreed that
we will put that to our members and they
will make a decision on that over the
next few weeks so we will ballot them
and they will have to assess what that
means to them uh weighing that up
against going on strike and so on and
they will make that decision now
that's backdated to July of last year so
yeah the the year one seven percent will
be back dated to July the first last
year and then five percent uh offer from
July the first this year and I suppose
the the advantage of of where we are is
that we have negotiated in some of the
other public sector disputes there are
pay-review bodies who effectively it
seems to me impose pay offers on uh
workforces without negotiations uh the
difference with us is we don't have a
pay-review buddy and frankly we don't
want one we actually negotiate with our
employers and that allows some movement
so in this case they have moved from two
percent to five percent now to seven and
five percent that's clearly a shift in
position and that's what our members
will consider
um equally it's still below inflation
and you know our members will weigh up
all the different factors that that they
face in in their lives in their working
lives and with their families
yeah 88 of firefighters and control room
staff I'm told voted in favor of strike
action I'm guessing that they want um an
inflation busting pay rise are you going
to hold out for that
look we haven't uh assessed we've only
got this uh offer late last night we
acknowledge it is a significant Movement
by our employers but as you say it's not
inflation busting certainly for year one
we don't know the position for year two
the 2023 position
um but it is clearly movement from our
employers and we welcome that and that's
the useful how useful dialogue uh can be
and our members will assess all those
things because clearly going on strike
is a big step to take as well people
suffer financial and other hardships by
going on strike but our members will
make that decision they've been involved
all the way through they told us they
didn't want two percent they told us uh
overwhelmingly they didn't want five
percent we will now put this offer to
them we're a democratic organization and
our our members ordinary firefighters
across the UK will make that decision
do you see your members as essential
workers
absolutely they they perform a a
life-saving public safety role every day
of their working lives and you can see
that's in in Stark example you've given
from the earthquakes uh now but here in
the UK every day keeping people safe in
making sure buildings are safe uh
inspecting buildings and of course
responded to 999 calls but fires other
emergencies uh absolutely an essential
Workforce considered key workers during
the pandemic
but given that the reason I ask you that
Matt is given that you're an essential
service the government going to stop you
striking
uh well yeah absolutely disgraceful
attack in our UK on on our rights and we
will continue to campaign against that
law uh and it is uh really undemocratic
particularly in the middle of a campaign
in the middle of discussions about
paying campaigns on pay to change the
rules indeed to change the law is uh
frankly undemocratic and the NRV
authoritarian examples have been drawn
where our comparisons have been drawn
with the situation in Europe we familiar
with the position of firefighters in
Europe and the position is completely
different to here firefighters have much
stronger employment rights and
protections and Trade union rights in
the countries that have been quoted by
government ministers so this proposed
law is completely undemocratic and we
will fight it every step of the way
okay it's good to talk to you do let us
know what happens as far as going back
to your members are concerned what
happens next thanks for your time this
morning thank you thanks Craig
meanwhile University staff civil
servants working in the government's
biggest department and NHS
physiotherapists are going on strike
today the latest walkouts overpay and
conditions let's get more should we with
Matthew Thompson joining us now from the
University of Sussex um
we just need to be a little quieter
Matthew they're just
pausing now
um
I'm going to throw to you you tell us
what the latest situation is
well it's the second K of 18 days of
strike action planned across February
and March by University staff they have
told us the union has said that they
won't hesitate to re-ballot their
members to continue that strike action
long into 2023 if their demands aren't
met it's gonna include about 70 000
staff not just academic staff also other
professional roles such as technicians
Librarians and the like across something
like 150 different universities and the
union says that it will affect over the
course of all the strike action
something like two and a half million
students although the national Union of
students has actually backed striking
workers now as to what their demands are
well they say they've been offered by
employers a pay rise of between five and
eight percent but that is not enough in
the words of the Union they actually
want something that's closer to 12
percent as well as reforms to pensions
and working conditions now what the
university employers say is simply that
the universities already many of them 30
of them particularly struggling
financially they're unable to afford uh
to increase pay and if they do increase
pay by the amounts the union wants well
that might put jobs at risk but I think
the likeliest scenario is that if
certainly if the employers don't come to
the table in the way that fire brigade
employers have done with an improved
payoff or the union has been very clear
they will rebalot their members and they
potentially will vote for much more
strike action to add to the 18 days of
strike action in February March that
could take us well right through the
rest of this Academic Year and
potentially into next as well
foreign
okay thank you
Siobhan's here with me Siobhan they were
pausing hoping against hope that
potentially
there could have found someone still
alive under the rubble but it looks as
though sadly again that's not the case
yeah that we've seen them do this over
the last couple of days a sudden whistle
everyone stops and then listens just
really hoping that this time they are
hearing someone banging on a pipe and
there have been stories of people being
pulled out even yesterday
but here it seems that this time no
they'll start again and then they'll
keep keep looking because although the
further away we get from when the Quake
happened the chance of people surviving
diminishes it isn't impossible for
people still to be found alive here I
remember years ago with the Mexico
earthquake they were pulling babies
actually out from maternity hospitals
long after that golden window period of
72 hours Nathan if we just look at some
of the buildings
um around you that gives you an idea
you can see it as a massive Rubble now
but that's what these building this
building would have looked like just 72
hours hundreds of people asleep in this
building um Siobhan when the Quake hit
and then the second one and that's the
tragedy of it bedrooms have become tombs
because people had no idea it just
collapsed on top of them we saw a man
here who he managed to get out his whole
family was trapped in sides he's had to
bury his children and he's still
standing here watching people go through
the wreckage of his old home yeah and
and I was just
pointed towards a lady whose 26 year old
daughter her son-in-law and her two
grandchildren also under this Rubble
still she says she's not leaving until
she knows that they are definitely no
longer alive and she wants to take their
bodies and bury them in the local
tradition we're going to keep an eye on
what's going on here let's bring in
Everett Aragon who's the co-founder and
executive director of uh Harry tasty he
um it's been what 72 hours since the
first earthquake hit
how long can people survive under this
Rubble
you're not much but still The Hope
actually you're not mainly operating as
needs not in the like rescue party how
big the rescue teams I hope you can hear
me uh so like the main concentration is
on the rescue right now and the shelter
maybe you can see I'm right now we're
not done I just moved from Antarctica to
Adana last night so yeah you can see in
the video as well there are some like
tons for the people from Adana and the
like surrounding cities uh so it's it's
been a it's been a really tough four
days for all the residents of these four
cities
oh you're back with us I'm sorry I was
just about to ask you which areas your
rescue teams are targeting
actually the rescue teams are mainly uh
like the operations are in the every
every city as needs map our operation is
mainly humanitarian Aid helping the
rescue teams uh to sustain their own
operation here and also the residents
who lost their shelters uh they are like
in 11 provinces in very different
districts and in The Villages the the
central governments local governments
rescue teams are working very hard still
uh to be able to find someone alive only
those those
everyone I'm just going to whisper
because again The Rescuers have called
for silence
any chance at all
that people could be found alive still
here
[Music]
okay I think we've lost um everyone uh
again so we're just going to move okay
can you okay we're just going to be here
because these rescue workers come down
Siobhan they're moving off the site now
when I've been at other sites they do
this
because they don't want any movement at
all on the top any movement at all could
cause the rubble to fall deeper into the
hole The Rescuers the orange helmets
have moved in closer yeah you can see
the guys wearing the red and black suits
are controlling the
the search here I'm just going to stop
because they're really listening now
oh
foreign
in the Middle with the headphones he's
holding a microphone into the pit of
this Rubble
the general workers have been moved red
the orange helmets with the red and
black jumpsuits are standing around
and they're trying to figure out if
anyone is still alive underneath this
wreckage
more movement now which would um tend to
suggest that's not good news no it's
interesting though because they have now
got that listening equipment I'm not
sure how rudimentary the equipment
they've got up there but this is the
sort of stuff they were looking they
were waiting for exactly because before
they were just oh no they stopped again
thank you
shouting into the hole asking them can
anybody hear them
someone
the area where they're gathered is the
exit to this building
foreign
members that we've been speaking to are
literally sitting a few yards away you
can't you can't imagine what's going
through their minds now but I think that
having that specialist listening
equipment does mean that there are even
people who are sort of whispering like
making the smaller sound at least
there's more of a chance of being able
to hear them
see the gentleman sat here with the
glasses on this side of the Hill
listening it's obviously a family member
hoping against hope that one of his
loved ones
might still be alive
remember of course
if you're watching us at home
when an earthquake happens you see this
sort of Devastation some people are
initially killed by the impact others
are trapped there is that golden window
of 72 hours yes that's right and I think
the other thing to remember is that when
buildings are weaker sometimes that
means the rubble that falls is actually
lighter so you can sometimes survive
particularly if you go into a place like
that's called a void they're going back
now so it seems like
other than moving the listening
equipment or
yeah
from what I've seen on this Behavior
over the last 48 hours or so it only
takes a moment or two and then if
they're here nothing then they continue
on
it's good news that they're continuing
shout and hope that somebody will reply
yeah and we obviously we don't know what
they can hear up there because they have
got that equipment like I was saying
sometimes when buildings fall if you can
get caught in a void you could be
protected so it's just as long as you're
not getting too cold you're not running
out of air you're not getting crushed
then there is a chance still that people
could be found here
dehydration is a big problem yes and and
these people would have been sleeping so
they wouldn't they you know they would
have been at their weakest when it comes
to dehydration and also children as well
we know there were children in there um
the other big thing that we've been
focusing on time and again is the
weather it has been so cold
and just to give people
um an idea of what's Happening Here
literally behind the camera there are
maybe
um I don't know a couple of dozen people
just behind us and then behind that all
of the on quite busy main road all of
these vehicles have been stopped yeah
they don't make any traffic noise no
it's amazing they just put their hand up
and everyone stops there all on the same
side they're all desperate for this to
be the time where someone's found
um
so what I'm being told is that they are
shouting
into the hole that's been created
is there anyone here
can anyone hear my voice
oh my goodness this is very emotional
isn't it the
loved ones just waiting here it's
absolutely heartbreaking
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
government Minister Claire cottino is
with us our Minister for children's
families and well-being Minister
obviously were paying due respect to
what's happening here
um as
the minister for that portfolio
um can you even begin to imagine how the
families here are feeling at the moment
no I'm watching it um alongside you and
I just looking at the the family members
waiting it's absolutely horrific and yes
I mean I think all of our hearts go out
to everyone watching and waiting to see
what's what's happening to their their
family members
um from our perspective we we are
working closely with the Turkish
government we are stand ready to do
whatever we can and we've been sending
people with some of the specialist
equipment I know that we can see people
using it right there as well as rescue
dogs and medical assessors as well
yeah and I think that the British
government also sending Aid is that
right further Aid we're working with um
the United Nations on a particularly for
Syria so we're supporting through things
like the white helmet but as I said
we're talking very closely to the
Turkish government and we stand ready to
do whatever's needed to help them get
through this
[Music]
that the Turkish government is
restricting social media
um because people have been critical of
their response to the disaster so far
well I think our work that we're doing
with the Turkish government is to
provide support and specialist equipment
and things like that so that's that's
what we've been focused on we're very
much acting
um in tandem with them and trying to
deliver what they need when they ask for
it and I think in terms of Crisis that
is our the right thing to do as an
international partner is to try and make
sure that we're responding to what we're
being asked for we know these moments of
Crisis can be incredibly difficult and
the response needs to be very
coordinated
[Music]
we need to condemn though don't we the
fact that people are being arrested the
Turkish government say because they're
spreading malice those that have been
arrested uh are saying all they were
trying to do was to communicate where
AID was needed most
so I'm not familiar with that I think
the focus that I've seen from our
government is providing the support that
we've been asked for and I think that
comes in the form of all the rescue
support that I've talked about which is
as you'll sort of see I think is is the
vital thing that's needed at this moment
from International partners
you know indeed and as we continue to
look at these pictures I have just moved
a little bit away from the scene because
obviously I don't want to distract from
what's happening but I did want to ask
you uh what you make of presidents of
landscas request for fighter jets
um a lot of Ukrainian people have found
themselves buried under Rubble like this
when missile missile has been targeted
at their apartment blocks
so I was I was at president zelenski's
address yesterday in Westminster Hall it
was I mean incredibly moving to to see
this guy who's showing unbelievable
courage in standing up for for his
country and you know again we've worked
very closely with the ukrainians right
from the beginning to provide uh all the
different types of support military
support and training and other things
that they need and of course he came
with a particular Mission yesterday he
wanted to ask about fighter jets and the
Prime Minister has tasked the defense
secretary to look into that I think the
one thing that I would say is listening
to people like air marshall Ed Stringer
and others is that it does take some
time to deliver fighter jets because
obviously you need to look at things
like training and all the support that
comes around these very specialized
pieces of equipment but we have provided
huge amounts of support to Ukraine it's
something that I'm very proud of of this
government and this country tree and
everything that we've done whether it be
taking in Ukrainian refugees or the 2.3
billion pounds of military support that
we we spent last year and we're going to
do I think the same at least again this
year we stand ready to do whatever we
can to support the ukrainians in their
war against Putin
you're brief as well if I may obviously
a lot of families here waiting to hear
about their loved ones I heard about a
six-month-old baby that was pulled from
the wreckage in his mother's arms last
night sadly
um they died under the rubble you want
to talk to us about family hubs what's
the difference between the family hubs
that this government wants to set up and
sure starts that were closed that had
been set up under the previous labor
government
so there's a few differences and you
know we're not completely sweeping away
uh the baby with the bath water as it
were there were some good things about
short starts but the the difference with
family hubs is we're very much targeting
them in areas of deprivation So today
we're announcing 75 areas who will be
benefiting from the rollout of family
hubs that we've looked at deprivation
and education and health outcomes as the
particular drivers of where we're
putting family hubs and secondly I think
a really important difference is that
shortstop was not at five and we know
the early years are very important but
actually family hubs are not to 19
because we want to have a One-Stop shop
for parenting which looks at the whole
family needs so not only will you get
services like breastfeeding for example
um parent baby mental health we know
that could be a very difficult time for
families but also you get support for
things that the parents might be going
through so relationship support might be
in their domestic abuse support might be
in their addiction support that kind of
thing as well because when you're
looking at educational outcomes and
health outcomes for children it's the
whole family that's important so we're
looking at putting all of those Services
one place so you can go to one place and
get all of that benefit whether it's
Midwifery Health visitors you know I've
been to see some family hubs we're doing
tremendous things and that's what that's
what we're setting out today
okay thank you very much indeed for
joining us Minister and thank you for
your comments on on the images that we
were seeing there and the support that
the British government is sending and
will continue to send to Turkey in this
hour of need thank you
uh Tamara is with us as we continue to
look at these images these were the
orange helmets that were at the top uh
um a top of this a topless pile of
rubble and rubbish these are the
professionals if you will being aided by
locals as they try to clear away this
Rubble to see if they can reach the 100
or so people that are still trapped
beneath this pile of rubble the golden
hours have now passed but they're not
going to give hope give up hope I should
say until they are absolutely sure that
no one is Left Alive under this Rubble
tomorrow's weather's tomorrow we heard
about the aid that was being sent here
by the British government and also the
minister talking to us about President
zielinski and whether indeed he will be
receiving the fighter jets that he's
been asking for
morning K just nail biting watching
those pictures yes MPS and peers listen
to president zielinski's powerful
address to Parliament yesterday and it
had a core message which was we have
freedom but he said give us the wings to
protect it give us the fighter jets now
Rishi sunak's response was it's part of
the conversation he didn't make a firm
commitment and president zielinski then
traveled to Paris in the evening to meet
president macron and the German
Chancellor Olaf Schultz made the same
call also got a non-committal response
why is that well I think Western leaders
are wary of two things first of all of
course the risk of escalation I mean
even a few months ago the idea of giving
um the ukrainians fighter jet seemed to
be completely off the table now it's
being discussed although the Russian
Embassy in London has warned off
consequences if that happens but there's
also really serious logistical
difficulties even a trained pilot would
need potentially years of training to
fly a western military jet they're not
the sort of jets that the ukrainians are
used to Flying and figures like the
former National Security advisor Peter
Ricketts who's been on our show many
times before he was warning yesterday
that he thought it was very unlikely
this would happen because not only the
training but you need really specialized
teams to maintain these fighter jets and
to provide spare parts and to fix them
up so it is all very difficult and
that's why president zelenski perhaps
didn't get the firm answer that he
wanted on that but there has been a
shift and certainly I think MPS
listening to that speech with the
rhetoric of Winston Churchill in there
and we've felt very much that the UK
wants to be giving the ukrainians
everything they need especially as we
head towards the first anniversary of
the conflict
okay thank you
um and as we continue to look at the
images here tell you what's happening in
just a second just also want to
illustrate that president zielinski has
left his hotel and he will be speaking
to the European Parliament this is his
Whistle Stop tour of Europe he's really
pushing uh the Europeans now for those
fighter jets uh he had been told under
no circumstances would that uh happen
when I interviewed him a couple of weeks
ago he said well the Germans said all
they could send was helmets now they're
sending me leopard two tanks I'm going
to hold out for those fighter jets let's
see what happens with that in the course
of the next few days Siobhan is here
with me just tell me what's been
happening sure so in front of us was a
building an apartment block and a shop
that collapsed totally fell um after the
second big quake and we've been watching
today these teams are searching still
trying to find any survivors there's at
least 100 people under there they've got
specialist equipment up there now
listening and we've been watching over
the last hour where suddenly everything
goes silent they even stop the traffic
on the road and they're desperately
trying to hear if anyone is still alive
so they're shouting if anyone's there
can you hear me and then they're
dropping a microphone down into the
rubble to try and hear if there's any
response
okay thanks very much Siobhan thank you
well joining us uh now is Amber kakar um
hello to you thanks for joining us um on
the program this morning as we continue
to look at these uh images
um
look if it's so heartbreaking honestly
it's just so emotional so she is the
international blue Crescent relief and
development foundation spokesperson
um tell me about the organization that
you work for it's on the ground I think
in gazian tip at the moment near the
epicenter of the earthquake what are
they reporting back to you
hi well yeah first thank you for having
us and I really want to just you know
it's morning time here still and some of
us who have been uh on the night shift
as well
um maybe are just starting
and I also want to thank uh everybody
who has
uh continue their efforts in all of this
devastation
um our team our first of all our
organization is a Turkish organization
uh we were established in 2000 so we've
been around for more than 20 years and
uh
we've had offices across that region for
many years uh implementing programs in
support of those affected by the the war
in Syria since 2012. and even before
that
um and so we have about six locations
between project sites and offices that
have been affected as you said we have
sent a large
semi truck to gaziantep with about 4 000
blankets and a bunch of other materials
and our team the main Hub right now that
we have fully established is in kiwis
and this is in our existing uh Community
Center fortunately
um it wasn't damaged too much in the
earthquakes and we've been able to host
hundreds of hundreds and hundreds of our
community members and we have multiple
points set up uh throughout QB's where
we are doing
hot meals and soup distribution as well
as like basic needs and
um trying to answer as many calls as we
can we already had established
communities in across that region so we
are hearing a lot from our community
members
um you know via text messages social
media phone calls you know people are
since we are really well known in the
region uh people you know our community
members down there have also like
forwarded our uh contact information to
people who are seeking help and so we
are just you know we're doing our best
so um we're in cubis gaziantep Sean
liefa is one of our other locations
there we are supporting the municipality
um for a shelter that is housing 9 000
people right now
um as you know there's I think maybe
over 300 000 people left homeless at
least in the region
uh and today and tomorrow we are focused
on
um continuing our efforts in kiwis
gaussians have been Sean Lyrica and we
will also ramp up our efforts for hatai
and karaman marash so uh those are the
locations on the turkey side we also
have a location in azaz on the Syria
side and we had been implementing a
health project with a mobile clinic
where we were traveling around to about
five locations in Northwest Syria so we
are also
um working with our partners to assess
the situation there and uh you know work
with our donors and partners to kind of
develop a quick and effective relief
program including
food and medical
supplies to Northwest Syria as well
as we look I continue to watch here they
brought in a
equipment to be able to cut through that
metal and they're also brought a chain
in to pick up that big pillar and put it
onto the vehicle that's waiting here to
get it out of the way to be able to get
deeper into this hole to see if they can
find anyone alive
um are correspondent Alex Crawford told
us that in antacio she has not seen any
military personnel helping with this
sort of work we haven't in the time that
we have been here on the ground
is that a surprise I mean I suppose the
government would say there are 13 and a
half million people affected an area the
size of the United Kingdom and the
military can't be everywhere
well uh I mean this is an unprecedented
uh Devastation I don't think any
anybody could be prepared for uh two
back-to-back earthquakes over seven 7.5
on the magnitude for the Richter scale
um so I I I believe that everybody is
doing their best as a humanitarian
organization we are grounded in
humanitarian principles and so we just
do our best on the ground to coordinate
with uh whoever is in the area and also
to have effective
communication mechanisms so that we can
also coordinate across cities yeah
okay
we must leave it there thank you very
much indeed